if you've never seen a monsterverse
movie if you don't know what the
excitement's all about oh my God H if
you've been hoping to finally get it on
the action this is what we've been
looking for check this
out a few things you should know before
going in first you don't need to know
anything before going in what what do
you mean uh uh what's going on nothing
nothing nothing what's Monarch I don't
know what about all the monsters what
about the monsters oh my God
oh my God what if you don't know much
about Godzilla or monsters in general
the thing is you actually do trust me
come on from cave drawings to
mythological characters around the world
we've been telling each other wild
monster myths since since since forever
and these guys just happen to be the
latest in that very long
tradition and here's the other thing
this isn't a monster story what are you
playing at here I know we just went
through a whole thing about monsters but
our show really is a people story and
the things we dig in into are very human
it is your family business it's not our
family business it's the family curse
and it happens to have a few monsters in
it cuz at the end of the day this show
is fun like really
[Laughter]
fun so just sit back
relax and en
enjoy